to our community we've actually been
able to take guys
who were in gangs who were
practicing criminal activity
and because of uh the work of associated
builders and contractors and the
training that you provide
take them out of those environments
train them and get them jobs
[Music]
can you believe it i am still here
that's right living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bring to you the awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to build
a community center on this much needed
block called o-block it's called o-block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
started calling it oh block well we
decided we liked the o but we're going
to change it to opportunity block i want
to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every single day to bring to
you rooftop revelations where i share
with you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions on matters as it relates to
chicago and issues across our great
country and then every now and then i
get to bring you some special guests and
today i have a very special guest
one of our partners one of our
collaborators her name is alicia martin
and she is with associated builders and
contractors of illinois alicia thank you
for being here thank you for having me
listen let me jump right in
it's cold so i don't want to keep you
out here too long
what brings you to the south side why
are you here tonight on the south side
of chicago on this rooftop um
having this discussion well pastor
brooks we have been working with you
partnering with you for about the past
five years and we are a statewide
construction trade association and we
are made up of contractors are our
membership and about five or six years
ago i met you through one of our members
mikey ramovich who you had on youtube
and um
we were talking to you and we thought
well this you know you're trying to help
individuals who had barriers to
employment uh who have seen little
success and experienced a lot of trauma
and i thought well we have construction
training credentials that are nationally
recognized we have a dol registered
apprenticeship program
and um we also recognize as an
association we have a social obligation
we're made up of employers and it's in
an industry where there's a shortage of
skilled craftsmen yes so i thought this
could be a beautiful partnership and
we've worked together and trained over
100 individuals in the last five years
and seen a lot of success stories come
from this program they just need that
opportunity to have some success in
their life you're absolutely right and i
want to thank you for the partnership
because it's been a blessing to our
community we've actually been able to
take guys
who were in gangs who were
practicing criminal activity
and because of
the work of associated builders and
contractors and the training that you
provide
take them out of those environments
train them and get them jobs
can you just talk a little bit about the
training and what it involves and how it
all works yeah it's it's we basically
created a 12-week boot camp style
training program where participants come
every day four or five hours a day and
receive three industry recognized
credentials and also at the same time
receive some um essential life skills
training and also resume writing
financial literacy and then we try and
mitigate any difficulties through your
work
that they might have with employment
down the road at the end of the training
so we take a holistic approach so at the
end they're ready to go in a
construction entry-level position and
have success and we've we've seen a lot
of those stories come through this
program so we've been very successful
and um one of the things that i've been
really excited about though that we just
did recently um that everybody is
ranting and raving about celebrating we
had our first electrical class
because normally we have always done
carpentry and not only was it our first
electrical class but we decided it was
going to be all women can you tell us a
little bit about that yeah we were
really excited about that too personally
i think women make the best electricians
they're very nimble but um yeah we had a
great a great group of ladies some were
uh coming through in their 40s some were
just coming out of high school but we
had 16 participants i believe all of
them are employed right now and uh
making a really good wage and i think a
couple have actually registered into our
registered deal program now to go on and
continue their electrical training so
that was really exciting yeah that's
awesome you know in this new center that
we're going to be building
a major component of it is
our trades our trade school
can you just talk a bit about
how that's going to be so important and
so vital
not just to our community but to
employers as well because there's such a
shortage and so
having this space dedicated toward
training all of these individuals we're
going to be able to train more than
10 or 20 or 30 at a time we're gonna be
able to have a whole network a whole
school how important is that it's
incredibly important we have an industry
with an aging workforce you know as well
as i do they've stopped training the
trades in high schools and we need to
bring that to your community so we can
have the opportunity there and at the
same time fill that talent pipeline
that's so much needed in our industry
illinois alone has a shortage of over
200 000 skilled craftsmen and women so
we need that we need that here in this
community and um i'm so thankful for the
folks that are supporting you up here on
this rooftop so we can make that a
reality absolutely well thank you to
associated builders and contractors and
all the companies that work with you and
all of those who've been providing jobs
for these young men and women who are
coming sometimes from some very tough
backgrounds but we've discovered that
just because individuals come from tough
backgrounds and maybe have gotten off to
a bad start that if you can provide some
opportunities some alternatives some
options
that things can be different and all you
need are partners and collaborators so
we thank you tremendously for being a
great partner thank you and thanks for
working with us we really appreciate the
partnership as well you know one more
thing before we go why should others
think about these type of collaborations
and partnerships with project hood
it's the right thing to do
um when you see struggling communities
and then you can come in and bring this
type of training here and see the
success that we've seen
it's the right thing to do yeah that's
right it is the right thing to do so
listen we are so grateful uh for fox
giving us this opportunity every day to
bring to you rooftop revelations and as
i always say god bless you and god bless
america let me thank uh our producer eli
steele for producing every single day
are a media person
to real for filming and making sure that
we get everything nice and neat to fox
and of course uh fox we love you we
thank you so much for this opportunity
today has been another rooftop
revelations and as i always say until
tomorrow
peace
[Music]